thank you and I'm stuck here and do you
want to get back to work tacos aren't
going to cook themselves right sorry
why
don't you tell me the chip is you to
work no Steve I got you and your bow tie
and get the out of here I know job
right I need my job cheering ginger
better known as I can hear one minute
alive ok just yelled I came here for
get back there you get back in your
little taco stand they might need a
doctor chris i'll be get out of here did
you get out of here what are you gonna
do your throw me out a little bow tie on
we're going to twirl around in circles
do get this guy out of here and get back
to work yes sir yes sir go back to doing
nothing go back to being unproductive in
it
I know you don't want this job or you
figure out a tuck taco stand
anywhere we're very god man Rick this
thing let's quit quit tonight
let's go off with manic let's go on
where's mom you don't need a work here
you're going home you got a home where
is this is this is a half of home that
I've got the only home that I've done
where do you live
rolling actually actually I'm gonna can
I just go back sorry yeah just say the
film again okay so wrong yeah what's up
with the first the film it's almost done
it looks great i sent you an email
didn't know about the producer that we
showed it to know you did not send me i
must substitute well anyway whatever
producer saw it absolutely loves you
performance he's done some really like
nice mid-level movies what produced you
know I i sent you an email you know
Joshua I can't i'm not gonna make my
name's sorry i was like jaja fiddle
Steen so crazy thank you sorry and you
should be inside making calls working on
the film where's the film where's your
editor why why aren't you in the Edit
Bay finishing the film the film has
edited it's done I mean it's pretty much
done then what's the problem what do you
need the finishing funds for if it's
done sound Matt the sound mix is all off
I got a penny closer I've gotta pay I
mean it's with the editor but I haven't
it's with the editor I haven't paid him
yet if I if I had a penny if I had a
penny every time someone simply told me
it's just the sound if you had a penny
for every time someone told you the
sound you be able to give me all the
money and I go to first right well like
I said I had an audition real close by
and I i was actually because Lenny and I
played golf a couple weeks ago I don't
know and Robert and I played as well and
no would be great oh so so yeah we
should arrange she's really sweet she's
a pretty girl um I think she's from Iowa
yeah and you know she's been out here a
few years I don't think she's an actress
good i was about to add yeah yeah she's
actually i think working on her master's
in lunch humanities mmm i think i think
that's what she's getting her master's
in I think you're right and and she
would just be you know I mean she's
she's kind of a bigger girl you know
she's cute though she's got a really
pretty face yeah one more time and the
speed up the action so it's like now
that that's someone's looking down in
action yeah yeah yeah okay i'm studying
say you know me just I'm filming I'm
just filming Lenny's reaction you're
feeling oh yes you know if it helps we
can even start with the dialogue just I
was a dialogue from the door you know
just the same value having a door but
wouldn't you know that just to help you
guys get into the scene all right a name
is just do your best to keep her
distracted and keep her from looking at
the camera that's Jenny blissfully all
eyes on me don't look away from him I'm
rolling and action doing I'm good hear
me she has
to her while I go get it Oh Chris you
can oh go see Gregor it's ok now you can
step oh not just anxiety these days all
right well you can watch maybe I'll just
take me way out I'm getting hungry now
mmm I try one of those here at Medellin
let me try one not bad not friends call
it baby crack actually that's not good
taste like father yogurts nada well why
wouldn't I use it some people you know
try and treat it like it's fancy French
perfume or something you know they like
savor it I'm into that
turn this way okay the brilliant part
that I really like I don't care about no
fourth wall see how that scoops
up into that that's cool i like that all
right now can we please do the same
thing but don't look at the camera no
let me say it again but don't don't say
that you're noticed the way the line was
to call you a nicer right now sorry
listen um i ah well you know I'm a
professional I know what I'm doing oh ok
Matt keep cutting sorry are you ready to
tapir
hey so you haven't finish that it in
that movie I know but um everything else
going on right now some stuff yeah okay
that's cool just haven't been just want
to let you know um you know it's really
cool that you put me in that last movie
I felt really good with everything i'm
not really doing anything right now I'm
just I'm just working right now I'm just
you know I haven't been able to get an
agent I'll think about it okay I'll
think about it right yeah that's cool it
just want to let you know that I'm i do
when turned into like exactly like a
nice enough pillar it's like you're
plotting so much Dempster this is like a
fun part of the night or not you're not
like just never employed and what she's
literally become like like nothing he's
gonna kill me do this is so isn't it
dies today yeah you're not better story
okay still rolling so how's that working
really well with your own okay come on
you're mr. going on pretty well yeah so
I you like to press that you are young
on our core bunch of different reducers
not really is it it's more like rap yeah
that's what I do I mean cuz i I've been
thinking about this because I can really
I can flow no seriously yes I'm dead
serious dude I can flow well when I edge
Olivia so if you can float those oh
really like right here right now right
okay I mean don't laugh i'm serious why
i'm saying you know if it's good
i have a beat it just well i got the
flow don't you know but i don't smoke
dope and i just said it just think it
liked flows it's like really really
tight I just been working on it for a
while and I just don't know if we can
like you know I like if I have a
chance love to use your studio man i
think i think i can like like set this
down it could be something